[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a sci-fi drama film
called the day of the triffids
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
dr bill mazen is a biotech engineer at a
research company called trifoil he
specializes in a tall carnivorous plant
called the trifids the plant contains an
oil that is an alternative to fossil
fuel
over the past 30 years trifids have
become man's best friend and have helped
eradicate global warming but many do not
know that the carnivorous plant is a
real danger to humans if left unattended
thirty years ago mason's mother who was
also a researcher was killed by a
triffid mason knows that if necessary
trifids will feed on humans its branches
are extremely venomous and can blind a
person in only seconds the breeding of
the plant is licensed and done away from
cities when a plant shows an abnormality
mason is called in to check on it while
he is at it the branches grip his arm
and his associate has to tase them away
meanwhile an anti-trifle activist
breaches the premises and enters the
orchard where all the male trifids are
kept the security cameras alert the
officials who send backup to get the man
out safely mason and his colleague lucy
run to the orchard and try to calm the
man suddenly a trifid branch attacks
mason's eyes but misses backup arrives
and gets everyone out safely but mason
is poisoned by a minor cut lucy rushes
him to the hospital in london after
giving mason an anti-venom the doctor
bandages his eyes and asks him to rest
for 24 hours in the meantime the entire
world is waiting for a meteor shower
that is about to take place at night a
reporter named joe clayton interviews an
astrophysicist according to him the sun
will release an unbelievably vast
explosion of gas and nuclear fire making
it seem like fireworks in the sky yet it
is proven that the fireworks won't do
any harm to humans or the earth he asks
the public to enjoy the once in a
lifetime experience to their best a few
hours later when it gets dark in london
the fireworks begin joe broadcasts it
live from the heart of london everyone
in the world watches the burning sky in
awe lucy feels bad for mason that he
couldn't experience such a unique
phenomenon passengers of an airplane
flying above london also witness the
fireworks and are mesmerized by them
among the passengers is a man named
torrence who doesn't appear to care
about the natural fireworks he simply
sleeps with an eye mask while others get
up from their seats to look outside a
few minutes into the fireworks a
blinding bright light flashes on the
earth because of it all the tvs and
radios lose signal the light is so
bright that people can hardly keep their
eyes open a while after everything ends
mason wakes up on the hospital bed with
his eyes still bandaged outside everyone
is panicking because the light has
caused all of them to lose their
eyesight a confused mason opens the
bandages from his eyes and can see
clearly back on the airplane torrence
wakes up and realizes what is going on
the plane is about to crash because even
the pilots have also gone blind amidst
the chaos he collects all the life
jackets blows them up and uses them to
keep himself safe in the bathroom the
plane crashes near a hospital in london
all passengers die in the crash but
torrance somehow survives with only
minor injuries after coming out of the
wreckage he smiles at the victory not
showing any remorse at the death of the
others meanwhile mason tries to find the
doctor in the crowd but even the doctor
is blind and has no idea what is going
on when he registers that there is going
to be a power outage soon he runs back
to the lab to keep the trifids confined
if the plants get out of the lab somehow
they will breed at an exponential rate
and kill everyone on earth somewhere
else the reporter joe clayton wakes up
in the middle of the ruins of a building
unlike most she still has her eyesight
joe makes it to the streets and realizes
what is going on she tries asking for
help but a blind policeman holds her
hostage urging her to take him home
before he can do any harm mason saves
her they plan to go to the white hall
together to find out what exactly is
going on
somewhere else torrance takes full
advantage of the situation and steals
everything he can from the stores he
also takes a policeman's gun for
protection and makes his way to a hotel
back on the triffid farm everyone
including lucy has lost their eyesight
the activist who is confined in a room
however can still see taking advantage
of the situation he opens the doors to
the orchard and lets the triffids free
the following morning joe and mason
reach whitehall but see that a crowd of
blind people has gathered in front of it
they try communicating with the blind
guards who start to shoot at each other
following that the two drive to the
triffid farm when they reach it the lab
is in ruins with dead bodies of the
workers lying everywhere mason finally
registers the seriousness of the
situation now that the triffids have
escaped they go to his lab and retrieve
a recorder that contains the triffids
noise mason has been recording the noise
over the years and has theorized that
the plants are communicating with each
other following that they drive to joe's
father's house to make sure he is safe
however when they reach there he has
already been killed and is being pulled
away by the branches of a triffid with
no way out the duo goes to a radio
station and broadcasts the news about
the dangerous plant they warn all the
listeners with sight to help the others
get to a safe place somewhere else
torrance reaches the current prime
minister's office and asks his secretary
about his whereabouts after finding out
that the government has collapsed he
sets off to look for weapons aiming to
become the people's next leader in the
morning mason sees flare signals coming
from the other part of the city he
realizes that there are more people like
them who have probably formed a
community when the duo finally reaches
the building where all the survivors
have gathered they see that the
officials are not allowing blind people
to enter the premises they are received
by michelle beadley an employee of the
home office and the chief of the
survivors organization currently the
organization is working on providing
food and shelter to the affected people
but is oblivious to the problem of the
triffids when mason tells them about the
real danger michelle asks him for his
expert advice a clip shows us that the
plants have taken over the railway
tracks and will soon be in the streets
of london michelle wants to bring the
little community of sighted people to a
safe place and start anew leaving the
blind to die
mason and joe do not support her idea so
they decide not to work with her out in
the streets a sighted man named coker is
gathering the blind people and is
organizing a search party for food and
water to help them he has become the
leader of the group torrance sees that
coker is in power and asks to join his
team they plan to raid the building with
sighted people to hold them hostage and
force them to help the blind meanwhile
mason plans to go to his father who
lives in the countryside his father is
also a bioengineer and a researcher on
triffids mason believes that with his
research they can find a way to contain
the plants however before they leave
they are attacked by coker and his group
and are taken hostage coker handcuffs
each sighted person to a blind one and
gives them the responsibility to help
them his heart is in the right place but
he is oblivious to the dangers of the
triffids following that they are taken
to a warehouse to collect food and
supplies but trouble arises when the
warehouse happens to be infested by
triffids joe is caught in one of the
branches but mason saves her coker
realizes that mason was right about the
triffids he asks torrance to provide
mason with everything he needs to get
rid of the problem but since torrance
wants to be the leader he plans to
betray coker when joe is alone he asks
her to broadcast another message on the
radio asking everyone to come to london
for aid in reality he wants to gather as
many people as possible to rule over
them unaware of his true motives she
agrees to do as he says meanwhile his
people take coker and mason hostage
kicking them out of authority they are
taken to a forest by torrance's henchmen
but are soon attacked by triffids the
plants kill all of torrance's men and
only mason and coker come out of the
forest alive the next morning they reach
a nearby church where mason is treated
for his injuries the church is run by
the head nun who claims that they are
immune to trifid attacks mason believes
there is something she is hiding when
mason gets better he leaves to look for
his father's place while coker stays
back in the church on his way mason sees
several bodies of nuns placed on crosses
set as a sacrifice to keep trephids away
it turns out that the head nun has been
sacrificing people to keep the church
safe he returns to the church and
reveals the truth to its people they
kick the nun out of the place and thank
mason for his help following that he
continues the journey to his father's
house which is still a mile away in the
meantime joe finds mason's tape recorder
that was found in an attack zone she
realizes that torrance has done
something to coker and mason to become
the leader in her next radio broadcast
she tells the people that london is not
safer than the place they already live
in hence they should stay put wherever
they are this angers torrance and he
sends his men to kill her joe manages to
somehow escape the radio tower and runs
to the infested part of the city the
henchmen try to catch her but are
unsuccessful they believe she can never
survive among the trifids and quit
looking for her joe is attacked by an
army of the plants but luckily she finds
a working vehicle and drives away she is
also driving to maison's father's place
having known where he lives meanwhile
mason reaches a small town where
everyone has died because of a triffid
attack except for two little girls named
susan and emogen at first they fire at
him believing he is a robber but stop
when mason explains he just needs a
vehicle to drive to his father's place
the girls have been living on their own
since their parents died and need an
adult to take care of them mason
includes them in the mission and the
three set out to look for his father
after driving for a few hours they are
stopped by a vehicle coincidentally
mason's father gets out of the vehicle
and asks them to join him they drive to
his house in the middle of the woods
that is fenced in by electrocuted wires
on going in mason is shocked to see joe
the two reunite relieved that they are
alive for a few minutes they forget the
troubles of the outside world and slow
dance together back in london torrance
is tense because he has no means to save
the people he has gathered he knows the
only person who can stop the plants is
mason meanwhile mason's father already
has an elaborate plan to get rid of the
trifids he has been breeding a female
trifid that is genetically modified to
sterilize the pollen from a male trifid
if these kinds of trifids are spread all
around they will make the entire
population infertile and eventually all
of them will die out but he needs the
pollen from a male triffid for the
experiment to be completed mason sets
out to hunt a male triffid and susan
comes with him there in a warehouse
trying to find one mason uses his
mother's recordings of the trifid noise
to attract the plant susan is attacked
by the plant that almost pulls her away
before mason jumps on it and hits it
repeatedly they bring its branch back to
the house and start the experiment that
night torrance gets his hands on mason's
report and finds out his father's
address they quickly leave for the
countryside to get them back in the
house a helicopter flies above
distributing pamphlets everywhere
through the pamphlets the group is
informed about a survivor's colony on
the isle of wight where people are
providing food and water to everyone
after defeating the triffids mason and
the group plan to move there his father
is feeding the female triffids as usual
but this time he listens to the triffid
voice recording while doing so the noise
makes the triffid aggressive and it
attacks the old man mason comes to save
his father and shoots the trifid dead
but it is too late because he is already
poisoned by the plant's sting now since
the plant is dead they have no way to
fight back against the trifids they
cremate his father's dead body at night
and decide to leave for isle of wight
the following morning while going
through the old stuff at the house mason
finds a black mask that he remembers
wearing the day his mother died he
doesn't remember much about that day but
he knows that he was saved by a trivial
group in an african jungle who knew how
to fight triffids the next morning
torrance and his men arrive at the house
and take everyone hostage he asks mason
for a way to fight the triffids but even
he has no ideas left an enraged torrence
orders him to come up with a plan one
way or the other or he will kill the
girls mason knows there is no way to
stop the triffids now instead he
prioritizes getting everyone out of the
house safely for that he plans to use
the trifid recording to attract the
plants when torrance and his people are
busy fighting them the group will have a
chance to escape that night the house is
surrounded by triffids just as mason had
planned torence realizes that mason was
behind all of this and asks his
right-hand man troy to kill the girls
troy however has had enough of his boss
and doesn't want to kill the little
girls he sides with mason and the team
and protects them soon the triffids take
over them and kill all of torrance's
people the others try to run away but
since the house is surrounded they are
trapped in the moment of panic mason
remembers the day his mother died a man
from the trivial group had made mason
wear the mask and poured triffid venom
around his eyes the venom tricked the
plants into thinking he was one of them
he does the same with everyone and
carefully steps outside the house lo and
behold the plants do not attack the
group just then torrance comes outside
and starts firing at them he is caught
in triffid branches and killed while the
group escapes safely in the last scene
they are on their way to the isle of
wight to start a new life and fight back
against the trifids with the knowledge
they have gathered subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out